rocket weather develop at least one
island and the moon that you have good
order
what about an article if anything - good
luck with immigrant labor morning
ammonia happy energy a paratrooper in
Valhalla
in 2014 the European Union saw 25%
increase in asylum seekers and Germany
has seen the greatest influx 200,000
people applied for asylum here in 2014
nearly triple the amount that came in
2012 this search has led to a backlash
from groups like Nikita
whose number soared following the
shootings in Paris and Copenhagen recent
arson attacks on Asylum centers and
proposed legislation to reduce
immigration are leaving many refugees to
question their future in Germany in
Berlin a group of young refugees use
theater to channel their experiences in
the country they call themselves refugee
Club impulse so basically you're
communicating through art to try and
start a refugee debate yeah this is it
there's not many places that refugees
feel welcome they don't know any place
no one could have tells them so it's a
club for Refugees organized by refugees
for Refugees it moves any human being to
see what the refugees have chance to
prepare their speeches their positions
and when you watch that you think it's
more powerful than any politician can do
the club rehearses several times a week
in a shared community space in Berlin
the performances captured the fears and
frustrations of refugees and asylum
seekers living in Germany shifting
between satirical and serious an
American phenomenon Lombard sodium
massacred come on Martin
dr. Fadi any aha
the Abu Newcastle with new al Morgan
[Music]
falafels hired
fortunately me the new one diastema
sorry
until emotional in Burnet have um debate
about NSA battle
are you late
forgiving refugees got my signal Surya
was hone in on a Cinnabon my name is
Kawana lots enough average didn't say
hard enough CS article it was a kind of
prison when you don't know the culture
when you don't have enough money to go
and sit somewhere where you can
communicate with people we call it that
time when you really don't know what
will be in the future okay oh yeah time
wisely you kalenna the lake has it
doesn't but it couldn't hurt me a little
bit me a person and another madman she
is no misciagna Gustave it up here I
learned to throw that anger what I'm
feeling inside to bring them on the
stage in contrast to the
anti-immigration protests in places like
Dresden the liberal city of Berlin is
home to demonstrations largely
supporting refugees and Refugee Club
impulse has begun taking his message to
the streets as well the play was called
letters home it's sending letters back
about the situation here in Germany
finally declared as future no one gives
us a voice we take it ourselves we are
meta to from starters
our one when melody I don't know the
shooting stuff but yet I know
yeah right limit like boomer husband and
me in only about Stanley
[Music]
now you mr. lammeter Allah Allah